bonjour à tous
prise illégale d'intérêts un véritable
cauchemar pour les élus fin 2008 un
maire qui présidait une association
locale a été condamné pour prise
illégale d'intérêts car son association
bénéficier des subventions de sa commune
une jurisprudence encombrante pour le
rapporteur du texte qui y voient un
frein à l'action des élus qui craignent
d'être condamnés
c'est donc pour limiter les risques de
poursuites pénales que le sénateur
bernard saugey a déposé la proposition
de loi examinée ce matin un texte aux
allures de sujets de philosophie pour
candidats au baccalauréat
il s'agit de remplacer la notion
d'intérêt quelconque parcelle d'intérêt
personnel un élu ne serait alors
condamné uniquement s'ils retirent un
bénéfice personnel
mais en ces temps où l'on prône la
république irréprochable
le gouvernement craint que l'opinion ne
perçoivent ce texte comme un nouveau pas
ce droit accordé aux élus tout de suite
donc direction l'hémicycle est très
bonne séance
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion de
la proposition de loi visant à réformer
le champ des poursuites de la prise
illégale d'intérêts dix élus locaux
présentés par monsieur bernard saugey
dans la discussion générale
la parole est un monsieur bernard saugey
pour l'ump
auteur de la proposition de loi
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre chers collègues je ne vais pas
être très long car anne marie escoffier
et mon collègue pierre-yves collombat
compléteront cette proposition de loi
je voudrais simplement vous donner
quelques idées force actuellement dans
la loi qui nous préoccupe
il y à tout élu ayant un intérêt
quelconque et c'est ce mot quelconque
qui nous pose problème en ce qui
concerne les prise illégale d'intérêts
car il est trop générale et en fait
cette proposition de loi contrairement à
ce que certains peuvent penser n'est pas
pour protéger des élus c'est pour que
les élus honnêtes ne soient pas
importunées etc pour que les élus qui
pourraient exister et qui sont des élus
voyous j'allais dire puissent être
condamnés y en a pas beaucoup
rien a quelquefois est donc le résultat
c'est que nous voulons cette proposition
de loi pour essayer d'améliorer les
choses mieux réprimer la recherche d'un
intérêt personnel
c'est quelque chose qui est très
important pour nous dans notre esprit la
deuxième chose sur laquelle je voudrais
insister c'est qu'il y a sur cette
proposition de loi de père spirituel
pierre-yves collombat et moi même j'ai
fait la proposition de loi en mon nom
puisque c'était un credo ump mais je
veux y associer mon collègue et ami
pierre yves collombat car nous avions eu
cette idée ensemble au moment de la loi
sur la simplification du droit
pas celle qui est en préparation mais la
dernière que nous avons voté et pour
éviter que ce soit considéré comme un
cavalier pour alourdir les choses etc
nous avons préféré en faire une
proposition de loi indépendante
troisième point
vous l'avez compris je pense mais je
tiens à appuyer sur cela à mettre les
points sur les i nous sommes attachés au
maintien de la répression du délit de
prise illégale d'intérêt contrairement à
ce que certains pourraient penser
et là je veux donner un exemple qui a
maintenant fameux puisque j'en ai parlé
en commission des lois etc et et chaque
fois que nous avions l'occasion d'en
débattre
c'est l'histoire d'un maire un maire qui
fait voter dans son conseil municipal
des subventions pour les associations
culturelles sportives de sa commune
prenons peut-être le cas du club de
sport de sa commune donc il fait voter
une subvention comme d'habitude et il ne
s'est pas méfié que dans ce club de
sport son petit fils était joueur de
football et avec un magistrat prenant la
loi au pied de la lettre
et croyez-moi ça existe quand même y en
a pas beaucoup et bien dans quelques-uns
eh bien il peut être condamné pour prise
illégale d'intérêts alors qu'il n'a pas
mis évidemment un centime d'euro dans sa
poche alors certains disent c'est pas
essentiel les cas sont rares et moi je
dis non parce que sur les trois
dernières années qui ont été recensés
c'est à dire 2005 2006 et 2007
nous avons eu 44 cas en 2005 nous en
avons eu 51 en 2006 nous en avons eu 49
en 2007 et sur ces trois années
il y a eu très emprisonnement avec
sursis
il y a eu 21 d'amande et il ya eu cinq
personnes seulement qui ont été
dispensés de peine alors le sixième
point sur lequel je voudrais faire
porter l'accent c'est une idée répandue
quelquefois lorsque vous êtes pris en
conseil général ou régional ou mer vous
pouvez dire à la personne qui fait
partie d'un organisme d'une association
etc
vous vous ne prenez pas part au vote
parce que ça pourrait être gênant et ne
croyez pas pour autant que la personne
n'est pas menacé
donc la personne et n'est pas protégé
pour autant malgré cette précaution
en fait ce sont les poursuites les
harcèlements moraux et non les
condamnations qui pose problème et je
crois qu'il faut que nous montrions
maintenant un véritable courage
politique
j'ai cru savoir que la chancellerie avec
lui quelques réticences un certain
moment je pense que si vous voulez je
crois savoir que c'est parce que
maintenant on est un petit peu au siècle
de la vitrine on gouverne avec les
médias on gouverne avec les sondages
c'est un peu la maladie du siècle et en
lorsqu'avec ses arguments la loi fauchon
aurait été présenté et bien n'aurait
jamais été votée et je pense si vous
voulez vous le savez vous qui est en
contact avec tous les élus de votre
département
vous savez combien cette loi fauchon a
été apprécié elle n'a pas donné lieu à
des débordements
c'est la façon de s'en servir qui
comptent donc pour toutes ces raisons je
crois qu'il faut que nous acceptions de
voter les uns et les autres cette
proposition de loi
et enfin cerise sur le gâteau la chambre
criminelle de la cour de cassation a par
une interprétation stricte de la loi
pénale récemment confirmé la
condamnation d'un maire d'ambert adjoint
et d'un conseil municipal pour avoir
participé à la décision d'attribution de
subventions à des associations
municipales qu'il présidait et ce
qualité bien qu'ils n'en aient tiré
aucun profit personnel et qu'il n'en
soit résulté aucun préjudice pour la
collectivité
je vous renvoie à la chambre criminelle
de la cour de cass du 22 octobre 2008
c'est bien donc la généralité d'été
le texte d'incrimination reposant sur la
notion d'intérêt quelconque qui conduit
à placer sous le coup de la loi pénale
des comportements pourtant strictement
conforme à l'intérêt général est alors à
la place de ce mot intérêt quelconque
mais nous vous proposons de mettre tout
élu ayant un intérêt personnel distinct
de l'intérêt général comme cela les
honnêtes élus qui sont légion ne seront
pas importuner et ceux qui voudraient
tricher seront embêté et je crois que
c'est une très bonne chose comme ça
j'ajoute enfin que verbalement
madame la garde des sceaux à qui j'avais
posé la question pour dire mais enfin
comment ça se fait qu'il y a des
réticences à la chancellerie m'a dit
qu'elle n'était pas au courant d'abord
de la fère et lorsqu'elle a été au
courant elle martelé fo des pour me dire
qu'elle soutiendrait cette proposition
de loi
je vous remercie merci
chaque collègue la parole est à madame
anne marie escoffier rapporteur de la
commission des lois
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
mon cher bernard saugey que je ne vois
plus
pardonne moi la proposition de loi que
j'ai l'honneur de présenter devant vous
ce matin s'inscrit dans une actualité
brûlante qui nous fait toucher du doigt
l'impérieuse nécessité de mesurer les
conséquences de la jurisprudence la plus
récente sur le délit de prise illégale
d'intérêt une actualité qui donne raison
à l'initiative prise par notre collègue
bermand sujet de vouloir mieux le
définir le délit de prise illégale
d'intérêt prévue par l'article 432-12 du
code pénal nombreux sont les élus les
fonctionnaires toutes les personnes
exerçant une fonction publique à
s'émouvoir des conséquences que pourrait
emporter la jurisprudence de la cour de
cassation dans son arrêt du 22 octobre
2008 ville de bagneux si elles devaient
être appliqués brutalement et sans
discernement à des comportements qui
n'auraient jamais eu l'intention de
violer la loi
cette proposition loin de vouloir
affaiblir le droit et protéger les élus
et agents publics veut tout au contraire
sanctuary zh et le devoir de probité
valeurs fondamentales de notre
république à laquelle chacun de nous
citoyens comme uhh uhh est viscéralement
attaché elle veut concilier deux
impératifs garant de notre vie
démocratique
la neutralité qui s'imposent à tout
agent public et la sécurité juridique
qui lui est due en contrepartie telle
était d'ailleurs l'objectif du délit de
prise illégale d'intérêts un délit qui
s'inscrit dans un vieux principe déjà
connu du droit romain repris dans deux
ordonnances de saint louis puis de
charles 6 puis dans le code pénal de
1810 seul son nom en a été modifié
et puisque au délit d'ingérence s'est
substitué celui de prise illégale
d'intérêt quel que soit ce nom il a
toujours voulu conforter la neutralité
des personnes exerçant une fonction
publique qui se voit interdire la prise
d'intérêt dans les affaires placés sous
leur surveillance
aux termes de l'article 432-12 du code
pénal le délit n'est constitué qu'autant
que les justiciables en raison de leurs
fonctions ont pris reçu ou conservés et
je reprend les termes mêmes de la loi
directement ou indirectement un intérêt
quelconque dans une entreprise ou une
opération dont ils ont au moment de
l'acte en tout ou en partie la charge
d'assurer la surveillance
l'administration la liquidation ou le
paiement
les mots utilisés pour caractériser le
délit portent en eux toute l'ambiguïté
que dénonce la proposition de loi la
surveillance peut aller jusqu'à être
interprété comme une simple association
au processus de décision et se réduire à
de simples pouvoir de préparation ou de
proposition de décision prise par
d'autres comme l'a jugé la chambre
criminelle en cour de cassation par un
arrêt du 14 juin 2000
quant à l'intérêt quelconque il peut
être de nature matériel ou moral directe
ou indirecte indépendant même de la
recherche d'un gain ou de tout autre
avantage personnel et sans contradiction
nécessaire avec intérêt communal il faut
bien admettre qu'en élargissant ainsi la
notion d'intérêt quelconque
le juge considère que l'infraction et
considérait même s'il n'en résulte ni
profit pour les auteurs ni préjudice
pour la collectivité
l'élément moral du délit résultant de ce
que l'acte a été accompli sciemment sans
qu'il y ait forcément intention
frauduleuse en mesure dès lors
l'épée de damoclès qui pèse sur la tête
de ses agents publics soumis au
quotidien à des processus de décision
qui entre pleinement dans le champ de
cet article 432 12 du code pénal
d'autant que les sanctions ont été
aggravées dans le nouveau code pénal qui
au delà des cinq ans d'emprisonnement et
de 75000 euros damende prévoit des
peines complémentaires dès lors qu'il ya
manquement au devoir de probité s'ajoute
ainsi une interdiction des droits
civiques civils et de famille pour une
durée maximale de cinq ans une
interdiction d'exercer une fonction
publique ou une activité professionnelle
ou sociale
dans le même cadre que celui qui a donné
lieu à infraction et ce à titre
définitif au pour cinq ans la
confiscation des sommes ou objet est
régulièrement reçus ou détenus une
incapacité électorale de 50 ha
qu'introduit par la loi du 19 janvier
1995 dans l'article l7 du code électoral
certes il faut bien admettre que
statique tic
statistiquement parlant et bernard ce
gel a rappelé tout à l'heure le nombre
des condamnations n'est pas excessif 50
condamnation environ par an sur les
dernières années de référence 2005 2006
2007 dont 14 puis 19 cuisse 10 à
l'encontre des élus il faut ajouter que
avec pragmatisme
le législateur a prévu d atténuation
m'aider et une animation pour les seules
communes de 3500 habitants ou moins sous
réserve que dans tous les cas l'ensemble
des décisions soient prises en toute
transparence
il n'en reste pas moins qu'en dépit de
cet assouplissement la rigueur du
sanction même atténuées a des
conséquences lourdes sur les agents
publics marquée par un soupçon
indélébile aux conséquences très lourdes
y compris au plan psychologique
enfin il n'aura échappé à personne que
le conseil constitutionnel dans sa toute
récente décision du 11 juin 2010 a
déclaré contraire à la constitution
l'article l
être du code électoral relatif à
l'interdiction d'inscription sur la
liste électorale
décision qui vient conforter la position
de l'auteur de la proposition de loi et
celle de votre rapporteur
cette proposition de loi je voudrais le
préciser ici avait été dans son contenu
présenté par notre collègue pierre yves
collombat à l'occasion de l'examen d'un
texte de simplification et de
clarification du droit et d'allègement
des procédures mais n'avait pas été
retenu car inopportune dans ce texte
bernard saugey l'a expliqué tout à fait
et rappelait d'ailleurs qu' il s' était
un texte qui même s'il venait de lui
était fait en parfaite cohérence entre
vous deux cette double démarche temps de
monsieur que l'on bat que de monsieur
sauge et de nos deux collègues montrent
à l'évidence l'intérêt du texte qui nous
est soumis je veux redire que derrière
ce texte il y a le devoir exigeant
impératif de concilier en pratique deux
points de vue celui de la loi et celui
du juge avec l'express l'interprétation
extensive qu'il fait de ladite loi de
voir exigeant impératif
je leur dis si l'on veut éviter un
blocage inévitable de toute action
administrative nous sommes monsieur le
ministre vous tous les élus ici et moi
même nous savons ce que veut dire
prendre ses responsabilités je suis
conseiller général membre de la
commission d'appel d'offres relatives au
transport scolaire jeu délibère donc
pour choisir les transporteurs qui
assure le transport des élèves
heureusement mes petits enfants ne
bénéficient pas de ce transport sinon je
demande et j'obtiens toujours en qualité
de conseiller général des subventions
pour les associations et clubs sportifs
de mon canton mes petits enfants
encore une fois heureusement ne joue ni
au foot ni au basket dans les clubs de
mon canton
sinon je serais prise en défaut
est coupable de prise illégale d'intérêt
n'y at il pas aussi quelques hypocrisie
à croire que parce que l'on ne prendra
pas part aux délibérations de l'exécutif
ou que l'on quittera momentanément à la
salle des délibérations pour ne pas
participer ni au débat ni au vote
on sera à l'abri d'une potentielle prise
illégale d'intérêts chacun à la
commission des lois s'est accordé à
reconnaître d'abord l'absolue nécessité
de maintenir la répression du délit de
prise illégale d'intérêt et nous
insistons mais en contrepartie la tout
aussi nécessaire obligation de clarifier
la notion d'intérêt quelconque chacun et
chacune a pu illustré d'exemples vécus
sur son territoire les excès auxquels
pourraient conduire une application
immodeste de la loi c'est pourquoi
unanimement notre commission a voulu
attribuer un éclairage plus juste
en concentrant la répression sur les
comportements relevant des manquements à
la probité le texte retenu intransigeant
sur le respect du critère incontournable
et essentielle de probité se veut
doublement protecteur de la neutralité
de l'agent public en réprimant les actes
qui sont nés carteret et en stigmatisant
le risque délictuelles
monsieur le ministre les élus
dépositaire de l'autorité publique
les personnes chargées d'une mission de
service public ou encore les personnes
investie d'un mandat électif public se
veulent et le sont dans leur grande
majorité suffit de revenir aux
statistiques que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure comme bernard saugey
ce volte exemplaire apportant leur la
preuve de la confiance que nous leur
faisons disons leur à toutes et tous
notre volonté de les aider à faire
fonctionner harmonieusement nos
institutions à ne pas paralyser l'action
administre
il surtout à un moment où se multiplient
les structures locales où se développent
l'intercommunalité ou les associations
sont plus que jamais nécessaires
le texte proposé par notre collègue
bernard seux g apparu à l'ensemble des
membres de notre commission un texte
d'équilibré de bon sens et raisonnable
seul son intitulé a été modifié pour
mieux identifier les bénéficiaires de
ces dispositions
sous cette modification le texte a été
adopté par notre commission à
l'unanimité
je vous propose chers collègues de
suivre son avis merci mes chers
collègues je donne maintenant la parole
monsieur jean marie bockel secrétaire
d'état à la justice
voilà madame la présidente nationale
terre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur bernard saugey
monsieur l'auteur de la proposition par
van der un projet madame le rapporteur
chère anne marie escoffier qui
inaugurait aujourd'hui cette mission de
rapportant fort bien d'ailleurs me
rendait la tâche ardue
somme toute je me dois avant de vous
faire connaître la position du
gouvernement avant l'examen de ce texte
de vous donner les raisons pour
lesquelles il y a matière à débat et les
raisons pour lesquelles j'étais porteur
en commission des lois le 2 juin dernier
un certain nombre de questions
d'interrogations et aussi de rappel
utile mais je voudrais dire et j'aurais
aimé le dire devant le président de la
commission des lois mais vous le lui
répèterai que cet échange que nous avons
eue il ya trois semaines en commission
des lois
de mon point de vue particulièrement
éclairant fructueux
y compris d'ailleurs sur des points
controversés on peut avoir une analyse
différente mais où il était important
que j'entends d'autres points de vue et
tailles y compris par la jurisprudence
eh bien on a la démonstration que ces
auditions des membres du gouvernement en
commission des lois
même si je le sais la commission des
lois a une grande capacité à se suffire
à elle même temps les talents ils sont
nombreux et riches mais je pense que ce
dialogue au stade de la commission a son
utilité en tout cas aujourd'hui on en a
la démonstration et en ce qui me
concerne je ne regrette pas d'être venu
en commission le 2 juin dernier
je pense que cet échange en commission
et ça vaut tous les coups de téléphone
ou échange de couloir
qu'on peut toujours interprété ou
contester ou et bien nous a également
permis au niveau du gouvernement la
chancellerie de du premier ministre et
de ses services et bien d'avoir des
échanges de prendre en compte un certain
nombre d'arguments et aujourd'hui
d'arriver en séance avec la position que
j'exprimerai tout à l'heure ses
remarques importantes est en fait je me
permet tout de même de reprendre un
certain nombre de réserves que j'ai eu
l'occasion de m'exprimer en commission
et je me dois d'exprimer aussi parce
qu'elles font partie du débat et ce
débat n'est pas aussi tranchée qu'il n'y
paraît
j'en conviens volontiers mais
combinaison également d'abord je
rappeler monsieur le président à
l'instant mais vos collègues vous le
diront l'intérêt que notre échange du 2
juin en commission a eu une manière
générale l'intérêt donc de ce type des
changes en commissions qui vont tous les
échanges de couloir si intéressant soit
il par ailleurs
d'abord la magnifique mais c'est ce que
j'étais en train d'expliciter mais vous
savez je n'ai pas été parlementaire si
longtemps y compris sénateurs pour pour
rien ça crée une culture un état
d'esprit à respect absolument
donc je reprends néanmoins sa forme
d'arguments que vous devez avoir
l'esprit tout d'abord la modification
proposée consistant à remplacer un
intérêt quelconque par un intérêt
personnel distinct de l'intérêt général
nous semblait effectivement
juridiquement inutiles comme vous le
savez c'est pas une position nouvelle de
la chancellerie qui avait déjà émis des
réserves identiques à propos de
la proposition similaire et vous avez
fait allusion monsieur l'auteur de la
proposition de ce sujet de monsieur
pierre-yves collombat on avait déjà eu
ce débat l'article actuelle 432-12 du
code pénal a repris la rédaction de
l'article 175 devance un code pénal
relatif au délit d'ingérence est devenu
en 94 de délit de prise illégale
d'intérêt les thermes a changé quelques
intérêts que ce soit sont devenus une
notion clairement connue de tous les
professionnels et la loi pénale c'est
vrai gagne 6 est stabilisée au moment où
l'on critique ses incessants changements
et il en va aussi de sécurité juridique
que tous les praticiens appellent leurs
voeux je sais que vous répondez à cela
que un certain nombre de décisions qui
font aussi partie la jurisprudence que
vous avez d'ailleurs rappelé mme
escoffier font que cette sécurité
n'était pas aussi importante que cela
notamment du point de vue des élus je
suis capable de l'entendre
je peux également vous invite à vous
référer à la jurisprudence de la cour de
cassation
cette infraction et c'est vrai que la
cour de cassation ça n'est tout de même
pas rien ne fonctionne qu un
comportement d' ingérence en aucun cas
l'objectif poursuivi ou le résultat
escompté par l'auteur des faits en
conséquence de quoi la modification sur
ce point précis n'apporte pas de valeur
ajoutée mais j'ai compris que là n'était
pas votre souci principal bon l'argument
de la paralysie de l'action publique en
raison d'une mise en cause systématique
des élus je vais pas trop le développer
puisque vous même au fond l'un et
l'autre d'ailleurs vous reprenez le même
argument que moi sur le peu d'affaires
de condamnations pour arriver à des
conclusions opposées mais sur lesquels
nous finirons par nous pour nous
rejoindre donc je ne vais pas reprendre
ces chiffres vous pour dire que
finalement le phénomène peut traiter
sereinement nous pour dire que
finalement
on ne doit pas tant craindre l'état
actuel de la jurisprudence mais ce sont
des arguments effectivement qui qui
comment dirais-je peuvent être
interprétées dans les deux sens en tout
cas pour éviter le risque des élus
locaux désertes des instances
décisionnelles des associations par un
public subventionné
je veux tout de même rappeler car cela
existe que l'article l 15 124 51 du code
de géra des collectivités instaure une
présomption d intéressement aux profils
des lui et les élus locaux représentants
de collectivités territoriales au
conseil d'administration ou de
surveillance d'une société d'économie
locale c'est mon cas également peuvent
est depuis longtemps peuvent ainsi
prendre part au vote de l'assemblée
délibérante 100% pour autant être
considéré comme intéressé à la faire
c'est tout même une sécurité importantes
pour éviter le danger mise en avant mais
je reconnais en vous écoutant car
j'écoute aussi qu'il y a malgré ce que
je viens de dire une réelle insécurité
juridique lié un certain nombre de
décisions qui sont parfois difficiles à
comprendre mais qui existent et qui du
coup évidemment affaiblissent l'argument
réel pour autant que je viens de
développer au fond nous sommes dans une
situation plus complexe que les uns et
les autres nous ne pouvions le penser au
départ vous vous devez avoir les coudes
ce que je dis pour que votre démarche
soit solide et puis s'inscrire dans la
durée et moi au nom du gouvernement je
dois savoir également entendre les
réelles inquiétudes que que vous mettez
en avant et qui justifie cette
proposition alors il ya une autre
question que nous avons également
d'évoquer en commission qui vous avait
d'ailleurs fait bondir et donc je la
formule ray de manière différente parce
que j'ai également si vous écoutez et ce
d'autant plus que je comprends
parfaitement votre sensibilité sur ces
questions la modification qui recouvrent
un champ plus restreint que l'intérêt
quelconque visé l'actuel article du code
pénal doit être je ne dis pas pourrait
ne pas être comprise jeudi doit être
comprise par nos concitoyens
nous avons donc ensemble dans un
contexte que vous connaissez tous qui
n'est pas des plus simples un devoir
d'explication de pédagogie en direction
de nos concitoyens des médias qui
évidemment commenteront nos décisions et
il suffira peut-être de prendre des
exemples aussi comme vous l'avez fait
des exemples évoqués par madame le
rapporteur je les connais je ne les
ignore pas mais soyons tout de même
d'accord pour dire que nous avons besoin
de bien nous faire comprendre et vous
êtes des parlementaires suffisamment
chevronnés et expérimentés pour savoir
que ce n'est pas toujours facile surtout
dans le contexte vous êtes là je vous
cherchiez tout à l'heure parce que
plusieurs fois je voulais m'adresser à
vous monsieur l'auteur et j'entends
géologie quand même il ya un
fonctionnaire qui parle dans mon dos
mais non c'est le secrétaire me voilà
rassuré bon allez je me rends discipline
je poursuis et j'achète mon propos donc
cette nouvelle définition en effet vous
l'avez compris risque d'être perçue
comme floue l'intérêt personnel est
nécessairement distingue de l'intérêt
général
je veux également rappelé que la
fraction de prise illégale d'intérêt
vise à garantir l'impartialité la
neutralité de l'élu elle n'est pas
érigés aux seules fins de prévenir la
dénatalité des élus mais d'assurer leur
devoir de probité ce que vous avez à
dire vous même rappelé tout à l'heure
nous sommes là dessus d'accord en outre
la rédaction actuelle de l'article
432-12 du code pénal
astreint les élus à un désintérêt sens
absolu afin de faire échec à toute
suspicion de partialité
c'est également le point de vue que vous
développez donc
nous pouvons nous retrouver j'ai compris
aussi je veux le répéter encore une fois
que j'étais arrivé en commission
d'autant que les problèmes que vous
évoquez moi je ne les avais pas
rencontré ni de près ni de loin et donc
j'étais venu vous exposer en commission
que au fond pour échapper à la sanction
les élus doivent s'abstenir de toute
présence directe ou indirecte à une
réunion de l'assemblée locale au cours
de la cades est adopté une délibération
attribuant des subventions à des
associations qu'ils peuvent présider
mais j'ai compris que nous n'avions pas
là une sécurité absolue en vous écoutant
en écoutant les exemples que vous avez
cités et c'est ce qui m'a amené
également à dans le débat
interministériel que nous avons eues et
bien sûr également au niveau de la
chancellerie à prendre en compte
au fond cette cette réalité qui existe
aussi en tout cas il est essentiel que
la probable la probité apparaissent
clairement c'est l'objectif qu'elle
évidemment nous voulons tous parvenir à
travers ce texte
faisons donc ensemble un bon travail est
un travail qui soit compris par nos
concitoyens je pense si je le dis c'est
pas par crainte je suis au delà de cela
mais nous avons tout même en mémoire le
débat récent autour de la présomption en
matière d'abus de biens sociaux
donc il ya tout de même des exemples de
débats qui parfois n'ont pas été aussi
bien compris que nous l'aurions souhaité
je pense que si nous parvenons à un bon
texte et tous les éléments existent pour
qu'il en soit ainsi
nous serons également conforté dans
notre démarche européenne et
internationale parce que naturellement
par rapport à ces objectifs de probité
de transparence de clarté et cetera nous
sommes aussi dans un dialogue avec nos
partenaires naturellement et il y va
aussi de l'image de la france et je peux
témoigner ici pour être souvent dans les
instances européennes ou internationales
d'ailleurs pour porter également notre
modèle de droit je n'ai encore fait il
ya quelques jours vous dire qu'il ya là
aussi un enjeu pour nous mêmes donc nous
devons avoir cet aspect des choses à
l'esprit mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
au vu de tous ces éléments et après vous
avez fait connaître au nom du
gouvernement
nos observations nos préoccupations est
ce qui explique que notre position de
départ tel qu'exprimé en commission
n'était pas une position aberrante où
irrespectueuse de votre travail ou
déconnecté de la réalité c'était une
approche de la réalité
nous avons écouté votre approche de la
réalité nous avons déjà eu une amorce de
dialogue et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons débuté ses les
débats autour de cette confession de loi
je veux au nom du gouvernement vous dire
que je suis mandaté pour m'en remettre à
la sagesse du sénat
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
ministre
dans la suite de la discussion générale
est à la par le tas monsieur yves
détraigne au titre de l'union centriste
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
chers collègues on ne peut pas d'un côté
dénoncé la désaffection pour le
politique et de l'autre rendre
l'exercice des mandats parfois
impossible de même qu'il est évidemment
intolérable que des élus profitent de
leur fonction pour s'octroyer des
avantages personnels
c'est tout l'enjeu du présent débat un
enjeu qui questionne la nature même de
la démocratie en particulier locale ça
démonte au logis et les conditions de sa
concrétisation
le débat n'est pas nouveau puisque
c'était déjà exactement la problématique
de la loi du 10 juillet 2000 tendant à
préciser la définition des délits non
intentionnels dite loi fauchon du nom de
notre collègue de l'union centriste
bernard stoessel a évoqué tout à l'heure
j'ai écouté attentivement monsieur le
ministre tout de suite
que n'at-on pas dit à l'époque de du
débat sur cette loi fauchon
il s'agissait d'une auto amnistie des
des élus qui voulaient se protéger etc
etc
mais tout le monde ou presque tout le
monde convient aujourd'hui qu'on est
parvenu un certain équilibre et c'est
vrai que on en était arrivé il y a une
dizaine une douzaine d'années avant que
cette proposition de loi soit examiné à
des excès absolument insupportable
aujourd'hui on convient qu'il ya un
équilibre et je ne doute pas qu'avec
cette proposition de loi dont
j'attribuerai la paternité non seulement
à bernard sujet mais à pierre-yves
collombat si j'étais bien attentif et
bien nous arrivions à un même équilibre
en disant cette loi fauchon l'est devenu
je dirais un stabilisateur de la vie
démocratique locale parce qu'elle a su
établir cet équilibre satisfaisant que
je souhaitais ans au début de mon
intervention entre responsabilités
politiques responsabilités pénales des
élus c'est donc la même question qui
nous est posée aujourd'hui une question
d'équilibré
la proposition de loi en recadrant la
prise illégale d'intérêts
rétabli un équilibre qui a été rompu
entre nécessaire sanction de la prise
illégale d'intérêts l'exercice normal
des mandats et je crois que cela
s'imposait le premier alinéa de
l'article 432-12 du code pénal je le
rappelle défini ce délit alors c'est un
petit peu long c'est un petit peu
rébarbatif la définition mais je crois
qu'il faut la rappeler ce délit de prise
illégale d'intérêts définit comme le
fait par une personne dépositaire de
l'autorité publique ou chargée d'une
mission de service public ou par une
personne investie d'un mandat électif
public de prendre recevoir ou conserver
directement ou indirectement un intérêt
quelconque quelconque dans une
entreprise ou dans une opération dont
elle a au moment de l'acte en tout ou
partie la charge d'assurer la
surveillance l'administration la
liquidation ou le paiement
en clair on se demande où est la marge
de manoeuvre de l'élu quand peut-il
intervenir sans prendre de risques hors
l'interprétation faite de ce texte par
le juge est devenu très problématique je
ne veux pas généraliser mais elle est
devenue dans un certain nombre de cas
très problématique
ou c'est parce qu'il présidait des
associations ayant bénéficié de
subventions communales des élus
municipaux ont été condamné pour prise
illégale d'intérêts alors qu'il n'en
avait pas retiré le moindre profit à
titre individuel anne marie escoffier
d'ailleurs là parfaitement illustré dans
dans les exemples qu'elle a cité dans
son intervention cette jurisprudence ne
tombe pas du ciel elle tient je crois au
caractère particulièrement floues de
l'un des termes clés du texte de loi
celui de l'intérêt quelconque il faut
avoir un intérêt quelconque dans une
entreprise ou une opération pour que le
délit soit constitué dans ces conditions
rien d'étonnant en réalité à ce que le
juge ait pu interpréter l'intérêt
sanctionné comme d'une part indépendant
de la recherche d'un gain de tout autre
avantage personnel et d'autre part non
nécessairement en contradiction avec
l'intérêt communal seulement voilà cette
interprétation place les élus locaux
dans une situation particulièrement
délicate dans la mesure où il leur
incombe souvent de représenter est-ce qu
lité leur collectivité dans des
organismes extérieurs qui concourent à
l'action publique locale
on en arrive à une situation de blocage
une logique je dirais de l'absurde qui
poussés à l'extrême conduit les élus à
encourir une sanction pénale par la
seule nature des fonctions dont ils sont
investis
il ya donc bien incompatibilité entre
l'exercice normal du mandat et la
répression entre guillemets organisé par
l'article 432 12 ruptures de l'
équilibre entre administrations
territoriales et sanctions pénales force
est de constater que la présente
proposition de loi rétablit l'équilibré
rompu en redéfinissant plus précisément
la prise illégale d'intérêt comme
relevant d'un intérêt personnel distinct
de l'intérêt général
elle exclut du champ de la répression
les élus siégeant s qualité comme
représentant de leurs collectivités au
sein d'instances extérieur dans la
mesure où il n'y prennent pas d'intérêt
personnel distinct de l'intérêt général
c'est donc un texte court certes est
rare qu on examine des tech o'shea court
mais je le crois efficace et qui
répondra parfaitement un problème
concret et que le groupe de l'union
centriste votera sans hésiter merci de
votre attention
merci aux chats collègues la parole est
à monsieur pierre-yves collombat au
titre du groupe socialiste
je m'entends bien
même la présidente chez le ministre cher
collègue bernard saugey notre rapporteur
que je remercie ont parfaitement exposé
les buts de d'autres cette proposition
de loi clarifier en la précisant la
notion d'intérêt délictueux afin de
sécuriser l'action de ceux auxquels a
été confiée la gestion des affaires
publiques
sans baisser la garde s'agissant de
leurs éventuels manquements au devoir de
probité
je me bornerai donc à revenir sur
quelques points qui me semble
essentielle et qui explique notre
adhésion totale au texte qui nous est
proposé un premier point le délit de
prise illégale d'intérêt concerne une
catégorie bien particulière de personnes
les dépositaires de l'autorité publique
ou chargée d'une mission de service
public ou investie d'un mandat électif
public
peu de nos concitoyens donc ils sont
exposés
ce qui invalide a priori toutes les
objections au projet de loi au nom de
l'égalité du citoyen devant la loi
l'inde et tentera habituellement réciter
dès lors qu'il est question de la
responsabilité des élus
en l'espèce la question n'est pas
d'assurer un traitement égal à des
égouts mais des traitements inégaux à
les personnes que leur position place
dans des situations inégales d'où mon
second point inséparable de la fonction
le délit de prise illégale d'intérêt en
bonne logique ne devrait pas pouvoir
être apprécié in abstracto sans tenir
compte des conditions d'exercice réel de
la vie de fonction hors qu'impose la
fonction ad et lui assurer la
surveillance toujours le fonctionnement
parfois d'organismes directement lié à
la collectivité qu'ils gèrent ils
représentaient ce qualité dans ces
organismes établissements publics
associations sociétés d'économie mixte
offices hlm
les élus n'ont donc le choix qu'entre
deux chefs d'inculpation potentiel
alternatif le défaut de surveillance en
cas de dérive des organismes dont ils
sont censés assurer la surveillance ou
la prise illégale d'intérêts tout cela
pourrait passer pour simple jeu de
l'esprit sans conséquences pratiques
jusqu'à l'arrêt ville de bagneux qui a
été rappelé et comme ça a été rappelé
dans cette affaire quatre élus
municipaux de la commune de bagneux le
maire deux adjoints et 1
conseiller municipal ce qui montre que
la question ne concerne tous les élus et
donc ne peut être réglé par le biais
d'une démultiplication des délégations
quatre élus donc on était condamné pour
prise illégale d'intérêt pour leur
participation aux délibérations et au
vote attributif de subventions à
diverses associations
parmi celles ci les associations
municipales et intercommunales qu'il
présidait et ce qualité sans indemnité
particulière et en vertu des statuts
mêmes de ces organismes
je conseille donc aux élus d'apprendre
par coeur et de se ré citer tous les
matins le dernier attendus de l'arrêt ce
site
l'intérêt matériel ou moral directe ou
indirecte par des élus municipaux en
participant au vote des subventions
bénéficiant aux associations qu'il
préside
entre dans les prévisions dans les
prévisions de l'article 432-12 du code
pénal qu'il importe que ces élus n'en ai
retiré un quelconque profit et que
l'intérêt prix ou conserver ne soit pas
en contradiction avec l'intérêt communal
si cela ne s'appelle pas marcher sur la
tête je vois bien qu'on m'explique ce
que c'est l'arrêt ville de bagneux
concerne seulement les associations mais
pourrait s'impliquer à la virgule près à
tout organisme extérieur d'une
collectivité voire aux opci dont il est
membre
ainsi lors du vote de la dotation de
compensation de l'impôt économique
transférer ou de la dotation de
solidarité communautaire
tous les membres du conseil
communautaire par définition intéressés
en tant que délégués communaux pourrait
être inculpé de prise illégale d'intérêt
il pourrait s'appliquer aux conseillers
généraux vont temps pour une subvention
relative à leur commune si on pousse le
raisonnement au bout pour le budget du
département conditions de possibilité
des subventions communales qu'un juge
d'instruction en plus demandés à des
élus siégeant et qualité toujours sans
rémunération au conseil d'administration
de la régie départementale des
transports
poursuivis pour leur participation à la
commission d'appel d'offres où ladite
régie soumet ce n'est qu'ils puissent
serait demandé s'il avait des enfants
bénéficiant du transport scolaire
départemental montre qu'aucun délire net
exclut la manière la plus simple de s'en
prémunir
c'est celle choisie par cette
proposition de loi a précisé qu'il faut
ce qu'il faut entendre
par prise illégale d'intérêts non pas à
la satisfaction dans l' intérêt
quelconque mais celle d'un intérêt
personnel distinct de l'intérêt général
troisième point cette modification qui
concerne exclusivement l'article 432-12
du code pénal laisse inchangés tout la
section trois chapitres deux titres
trois livres 4 manquement au devoir de
probité dudit code pénal inchangé
l'article 432 10 concussion 432 11
trafic d'influencé 432-13 porte ou flash
432 15 soustraction et détournement de
biens au sein même de l'article 413
432-12 elle ne concerne pas les cas où
existe un intérêt personnel propre même
légitime de l'élu questions abordées par
les alinéas 2 à 5 de l'article
alenya qui ne s'applique d'ailleurs aux
élus municipaux des communes moins 3500
habitants
et là aussi il y aurait beaucoup à dire
mais nous n'en dirons rien par exemple
j'aimerais fait l'expérience en tant que
maire d'une commune de moins de 3500
habitants fait l'expérience ces demandes
et j'avais l'intention de louer des
locaux municipaux pour faire un bureau
car si devenu sénateur j'ai demandé à la
commission
j'ai demandé conseil donc au service
central de prévention de la corruption
si je pouvais le faire il a été
déconseillé de le faire si évidemment
suivi l'avis du 10 de ce service qui est
joue un rôle tout à fait essentiel donc
là il y avait bien un seul intérêt était
parfaitement légitime suivant la
procédure et c'est donc c'était
impossible très bien donc c'est même pas
ça c'est même pas un intérêt propre
c'est un intérêt donc personnel qui ne
serait pas personnel donc il serait
assez étrange de voir refuser la
modification de bon sens proposé ici
alors que des pratiques autrement plus
attentatoires à la mort un clic à la
moralité publique prospère sans susciter
des moments particuliers ainsi si un
ancien employé d'une entreprise
spécialisée dans la gestion des services
d'eau d'assainissement d'eaux revire
ménagères devenu maire ne peut pas
participé à l'instruction des affaires
relatives à l'association qu'il préside
est-ce qualité
il peut parfaitement en toute légalité
concédé ses services municipaux
bien sûr en respectant le formalisme de
la paix la concurrence à son ancien
employeur on pourrait appeler ça du
pantouflage à l'envers le pantouflage
proprement dit est en réprimer ou plutôt
limité on en a des exemples par
l'article 432-13 du code pénal avec ce
paradoxe que soulignait déjà le rapport
de l'année 2000 du service central de
prévention de la corruption je cite
comment malgré un cadre juridique si
rigoureux un sentiment de suspicion
peut-il se faire jour
comment le pantouflage en vient-il à
être stigmatisée
même lorsqu'il ne constitue pas une
infraction même lorsqu'il ne constitue
pas une infraction l'expression parle
d'elle-même je conseille donc la lecture
de ce rapport aux âmes particulièrement
chatouilleuse sur le chapitre moralité
publique ou plus exactement émotion
médiatique
cinquième point pour apprécier l'effet
pratiques et humains de la législation
on ne peut se contenter de dire que la
répression du délit de prise illégale
d'intérêt est mesuré c'est le seul point
sur lequel je ne suis pas totalement
d'accord avec notre notre rapporteur
d'abord les statistiques fournies par la
chancellerie sont pour l'essentiel
antérieure à l'arrêt ville de bagneux
qui change entièrement la donne pour
sauver le ensuite plus que la lourdeur
des peines direct et complémentaires
dont on peut raisonnablement penser
qu'elles ne concernent que des prévenus
ayant manqué à leur devoir de probité
paradoxalement c'est la légèreté de bon
nombre des peines prononcées qui
interroge que penser des dispense de
peine sinon qu'elle sanctionne quelqu'un
d'honnête
c'est évidemment de ces élus dont nous
parlons les autres n'ont que ce qu'ils
méritent
il y a peu de condamnations nous avez
vous dit monsieur le ministre en
commission des lois et vous l'avez
rapport les ai rappelés
elles sont légères et vous avez dit
parfois justifiées quel aveu si ces
condamnations sont parfois justifiées
c'est que souvent elles ne le sont pas
oui c'est dans le rapport je me
permettrai pas inventer nos toiles notre
rapporteur à replacer notre réflexion
dans une continuité historique remontant
à saint louis et à charles ciss charles
ciss l'inoubliable auteur d'une
ordonnance sur le blasphème dont je vous
conseille la lecture
charles ciss il fut d'abord le bien aimé
avant de sombrer dans une folie
meurtrière et de devenir charles le foll
j'y vois comme un signe s'agissant de
notre code pénal sous sections prise
illégale d'intérêts si un chat collègues
la parole est à monsieur jean pierre
vial au titre de l'union pour un
mouvement populaire
même le président monsieur le ministre
mais sa collègue
toute personne doit répondre de ses
actes et de leurs conséquences autant
sur le plan civil que sur le plan pénal
non seulement cette règle de droit
commun n'échappe pas à la personne
investie de l'autorité publique
fonctionnaires élus officier ministériel
mais son application est fréquemment
élargi voir durci en vertu d'un principe
très simple que le porteur de cette
autorité publique doit être un garant de
l'autorité qu'il représente ou de la
fonction qu'ils assument leurs
administratif a construit dans le temps
sur la base d'une jurisprudence et d'une
doctrine solide
la notion de la faute détachable ou dans
du service et de ses conséquences sur le
plan pénal la simple le simple fait de
commettre une infraction des temps
investi l'autorité publique entraîne le
durcissement de la sanction ward la
qualification pouvant aller jusqu à
criminaliser des faits qui n'auraient
reçu qu'une qualification délictuelle au
regard du droit commun les domaines
d'activité de plus en plus variées et
complexes relevant du champ public et du
champ privé notamment dans le domaine
économique ont conduit l'autorité
publique et le législateur à mettre en
place des contrôles de déontologie de
plus en plus rigoureux ces principes et
cette rigueur doivent être une règle est
une exigence
mais cette exigence note de droit ne
peut aller sans la précision de la règle
et de son caractère normatif et cela
d'autant plus quand en matière pénale
on s'éloigne du caractère intentionnel
des faits pour n'en retenir que le
salaire le seul caractère matériel il ya
quelques années déjà madame sens vers
lagord non pas en sa qualité de relance
hier mais en qualité de rapporteur du
conseil d'état sur l'activité
législative souligné les risques du
nombre croissant de theix législatives
de l'insécurité juridique qui pourrait
en résulter
combien de fois des magistrats ne nous
ont-ils pas soulevé les difficultés qui
en résulte est pour eux allant même
jusqu'à considérer que dans bien des cas
la difficulté pour eux ne réside pas
tant dans l'appréciation des faits qui
leur étaient soumis mais de la bonne
application des textes ou regardent leur
nombre de leur diversité
leur diversité voire de leur complexité
les élus locaux qui ne l'oublions pas
sont la plupart du temps des élus de
petites communes avec des services
administratifs très réduit voire
inexistant amener ses qualités a
représenté la collectivité et
l'assemblée dont il émane au sein de ce
qu'on appelle communément les organismes
extérieurs qu'il soit de droit public ou
de droit privé ces établissements
publics ou association para publics
concours à l'action publique locale en
dans des missions d'intérêt public ou
d'intérêt général
irremplaçable dans notre droit positif
la prise illégale d'intérêts se définit
comme un manquement au devoir de probité
de la part de toute personne exerçant
des fonctions publiques
or l'absence de qualification précise de
la notion d'intérêt a conduit la
jurisprudence la plus récente sur ce
point émanant de l'arrêt de la cour de
cassation que je ne reprendrai pas pour
avoir été longuement développée ainsi
dans un de ces considérants l'arrêt
précis de l'arrêt précité
la chambre criminelle la cour a indiqué
que l'infraction est constituée même
s'il ne résulte ni profit pour les
auteurs ni préjudice pour la
collectivité comme cela été longuement
développée dès lors la cour considère
que la prise illégale d'intérêt ne se
consomme pas par le seul abus de sa
fonction
indépendamment de la recherche d'un gain
ou d'un avantage personnel non seulement
les effets de cet ouvrier de cette
jurisprudence n'aurait plus aucun lien
avec la notion de probité a préservé
mais entraînerait de lourdes
conséquences à l'égard des élus qui
refuserait à l'avenir d'assumer des
décisions des responsabilités ou des
représentations dans des structures
extérieures qu'il considérait comme si
c'est comme si ces petits bouts de leur
faire courir le risque
mes chers collègues nous sommes tous
dans des assemblées délibérantes nous
sommes pour beaucoup dans des
commissions permanentes qui dans cet
hémicycle n'a pas participé
j'allais dire je vais peser mes mots à
ces échanges ou untel lève la main en
disant monsieur le président je vous
demande de ne pas me mettre au procès
verbal ou un autre parce qu'il est
inattentif et parle à son collègue est
interpellé en rap
tu es président de l'opac faudrait
peut-être que tu te fasses m procès
verbal tu es président du cal pact ou de
l'adil il faudrait peut-être que cette
décision ne concerne pas en un mot il
est des fois où on se regarde pour voir
si le quorum est encore assurée en ayant
exclu tous ceux qui pourraient être
concernés par le procès verbal est ce
cela l'application rigoureuse du droit
eh bien je crois qu'aujourd'hui par
l'exemple du droit de sa rigueur et de
ces exemples de la vie au quotidien
nous sommes amené monsieur le ministre
en qualité de législateur à prendre
notre responsabilité et je dirais que je
suis très sensible monsieur le ministre
à l'état d'esprit dans lequel on vous a
senti l'autre jour en commission et à
l'accueil et à la conclusion à laquelle
vous êtes arrivé il y un instant en vous
à rapportant à la sagesse du sénat ce
que l'on attendait mais dont on n'était
pas complètement sûr jusqu'à ce que
puisque à ce que vous en pensiez la
formule
voilà monsieur le ministre effectivement
non seulement la nécessité d'encadrer au
mieux l'action publique et d'empêcher
des dysfonctionnements voire paralysie
la présente proposition de loi vise à
définir plus précisément la prise
d'intérêt illégale à travers cette
proposition de loin notre collègue
bernard saugey dont je tiens à saluer
l'initiative a su concilier deux
impératifs qui l'un et l'autre
garantissent la force et la vitalité de
notre vie démocratique à savoir la
neutralité à laquelle doit se soumettre
tout agent public et la sécurité
juridique qui lui est due en
contrepartie je tiens à souligner qu'à
travers cette nouvelle définition la
poursuite d'un intérêt moral sera
toujours sanctionnés au même titre que
la recherche de profits matériels ou
financiers
en effet monsieur ministre ce texte qui
est souvent un autre examen ne vise ni
amoindrir la responsabilité des élus et
fonctionnaires
ni assouplir les sanctions mais à
protéger l'action des élus en préservant
la neutralité de leur fonction publique
tout en réprimant la recherche de
l'intérêt particulier
par ailleurs la commission but durant
les difficultés d'application des
dispositions du code pénal a souhaité
lui attribue un éclairage plus juste en
concentrant la répression sur les
comportements relevant des manquements à
la probité
en attendant ceux d'aix notre commission
s'est voulue intransigeante sur le
respect du critère de probité
afin de protéger doublement la
neutralité de l'agent public
il est prévu d'une part de réprimer les
actes qui s'en écartent et d'autre part
d'indiquer à intéresser la mesure du
risque délictuelles je tiens donc à
souligner l'excellent travail de notre
rapporteur anne marie escoffier et de
l'extrême qualité de son approche
à l'initiative de laquelle notre
commission a souhaité modifier
l'intitulé de la proposition de loi
comme vous l'avait indiqué mais sa
collègue ces propositions visent à
clarifier la notion d'intérêt et à lever
les incertitudes pesant pour les agents
publics sur la compatibilité avec la loi
pénale des actes qui sont appelés à
commettre et ce qualité de plus on ne
contenant pas les destinataires du texte
aux seuls élus locaux le titre de la
présente proposition de loi est
désormais en conformité avec le
dispositif que les membres du groupe
l'ump moi même souhaitons adopter
en effet l'article 432-12 du code pénal
concerne non seulement les élus mais
également les fonctionnaires et plus
largement les dépositaires de l'autorité
publique en charge de missions de
service public qui peuvent être des
agents de droit privé comme les
officiers ministériels
nous nous réjouissons donc de ce texte
qui fait l'objet d'une approche
juridique rigoureuse ayant été adoptée à
l'unanimité par notre commission des
lois et pour conclure monsieur le
ministre j'ai bien compris que
finalement s'il n'y avait qu'un dernier
doute dans votre esprit
c'était pas tant celui de la rigueur
morale de la rigueur juridique de la
pertinence du texte qui était soumis
mais c'était la pesanteur de ce qui
pouvait résulter des médias
soyons clairs mais notre société
n'at-elle pas non plus à progresser en
comptant sur les médias pour que les
médias
et dieu sait qu'il y à des événements
récents jeunes titre
par lesquels qui ont montré à quel point
notre société y compris notre jeunesse
ont besoin de normes de valeur de clarté
et ce n'est pas en restant dans le flou
juridique que l'on se fait respecter des
médias mais en montrant aux médias que
la règle est aussi respectueuse de vertu
et que les médias ou en être les porte
paroles et non pas toujours à dénigrer
ce que fait la chose publique
en tout cas je peux vous dire qu'en
concluant mon intervention je suis un
élu de la république
fier de l'être et des valeurs qu'il
représente merci chers collègues je
donne maintenant la parole à madame
eliane assassi au titre du groupe
communiste républicain citoyen sénateurs
du parti de gauche
bonjour madame la présidente monsieur
secrétaire d'état mais chers collègues
je croyais d'emblée il me semble utile
de dire que la proposition de loi sur
laquelle nous sommes invités à nous
prononcer n'a pas pour objet de revenir
sur une accumulation nécessaire les élus
qui manquent à leur devoir de probité
doivent être sanctionnés la loi pénale
doit garantir aux citoyens le respect de
ceux dû revoir et toute confusion entre
l'intérêt propre d'un élu et l'intérêt
public doit donc être lourdement
sanctionnés toutefois pour que la loi
pénale joue pleinement son rôle de garde
fou elle doit être parfaitement
intelligible of us force est de
constater qu'avec la nature avec
l'interprétation qui lui donne à l'heure
actuelle que lui donne à l'heure
actuelle la chambre criminelle de la
cour de cassation
cet objectif est loin d'être atteint
l'article 432-12 du code pénal
sanctionne je cite le fait pour une
personne dépositaire de l'autorité
publique ou chargée d'une mission de
service public ou par une personne
investie d'un mandat électif public de
prendre recevoir ou conserver
directement ou indirectement un intérêt
quelconque dans une entreprise ou dans
une opération dont elle a au moment de
l'acte en tout ou partie la charge
d'assurer la surveillance
l'administration la liquidation ou le
paiement fin de citation pour préciser
le champ d'application de cet article la
chambre criminelle a au fil de sa
jurisprudence donné une interprétation
toujours plus extensive de la notion
d'intérêt quelconque sanctionnant
d'abord la prise un intérêt personnel
l'article 432-12 du code pénal
sanctionne actuellement les élus je cite
agissant dans l'intérêt communal en
dehors de tout intérêt personnel
apparent au mépris du principe
d'interprétation stricte de la loi
pénale la cour de cassation a donc
choisi de donner une interprétation de
plus en plus extensive à la notion
d'intérêt quelconque comme l'a relevé un
analyste
où s'arrête le soupçon lorsqu'il n'est
nul besoin d'établir l'intention ni le
profit en glissant de l'intérêt
personnel à l'intérêt moral la chambre
criminelle empêche tout des limitations
précis du délit dont elles se rendent
coupables les élus les premières
victimes de cette dérive
jurisprudentielle ont été les élus
municipaux de la ville de bagneux
condamné pour avoir participé au vote de
subventions à des associations qu'il
présidait ainsi au terme cela a été dit
de l'arrêt de la haute assemblée
d'octobre 2008 confirmant l'arrêt de la
cour d'appel de versailles
contact condamnant ces élus l'intérêt
matériel ou moral direct aux intérêts
directs pris part des élus municipaux en
participant aux voix des subventions
bénéficiant l'association qu'il préside
entre dans les prévisions de l'article
432-12 du code pénal qu'ils n'apportent
que ces élus n'en ai retiré un
quelconque profit et que l'intérêt prix
ou conserver ne soit pas en
contradiction avec l'intérêt communal
les élus faisait pourtant valoir qu'il
n'avait pris aucun intérêt distinct de
l'intérêt général dans la mesure où les
associations servait des objectifs
d'intérêt communal et qu'ils n'avaient
perçu aucune rémunération
cet argumentaire n'a pas convaincu la
haute assemblée il est pourtant pour le
moins choquant qu'en l'absence de tout
profit personnel les élus soient quand
même condamné la jurisprudence donc
appel actuel fait peser en effet une
épée de damoclès au-dessus de la tête de
chaque et vue il est donc temps de
rendre à l'artiste 342 2-12
bénac son véritable sens ici la raison
pour laquelle nous voterons pour cette
proposition de loi
merci chers collègues la parole est un
monsieur daniel marsin au titre du
groupe du rassemblement démocratique et
social européen
exit même la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il
appartient au législateur d'apprécier la
cohérence de la loi au regard de
l'interprétation faite des principes
qu'il a posés et de cauet de la corriger
s'il est nécessaire
avec cette proposition de loi de notre
collègue bernard soguel sauge et qui
vise à réformer le champ des poursuites
de la prise illégale d'intérêt des élus
locaux nous sommes le semble-t-il
typiquement dans ce rôle
chacun ici et on l'a dit convient que
les élus locaux et les fonctionnaires se
doivent de respecter une intégrité à
toute épreuve sous peine non seulement
de se discréditer mais ça paie également
les fondements mêmes de l'étape de la
démocratie en général
cette conviction à d'ailleurs motivé
l'adoption de plusieurs lois importantes
destinées à éviter le soupçon du tous
pourris ressenti parfois par leurs
concitoyens
je pense en particulier au loin de 92 et
93 qui ont été votées comme l'a rappelé
notre reporter anne marie escoffier
le délit de prise illégale d'intérêt
comme celui de favoritisme soit
précisément tracées dans le nouveau code
pénal parmi les adeptes au moment du
devoir de probité
ils sont aussi intégrés dans un livre
dudit code consacré aux crimes et délits
contre la nation l'état et la paix
publique ou le trouve pêle-mêle la
trahison l'espionnage la violation de
secret de défense nationale l'attentât
le complot le terrorisme les goûts de
combat et cetera
c'est dire l'importance que le
législateur a voulu accorder à ces chefs
d'infraction mais dans sa volonté
légitime de lutter contre des pratiques
peu recommandables
il a peut-être ratisser un peu large au
risque de mettre dans le même sac des
agents malhonnêtes qui doivent être
sanctionnés avec des élus des
fonctionnaires agissante tout
toute bonne foi comment est ce possible
c'est que pour son talent ici au délit
de prise illégale d'intérêts l'article
432-12 du code pénal loin des défilés
explicitement ce qui est permis et ce
qui ne l'est pas ne fixe aucun contour à
la frontière infranchissable qu'il
instaurera juste titre entre les sphères
publique et privée dans la mesure où le
texte d'accumulation mentionne la prise
d'intérêt la prise d'un intérêt
quelconque et n'opère aucune distinction
entre la nature et cet intérêt
l'interprétation par les juges est
imposée de fait la cour de cassation
considère et on l'a dit qu'un intérêt
moral ou en été ou en indirect par
l'interposition de personnes suffit à
caractériser le délit par ailleurs peu
importe que les lieux où le
fonctionnaire est motivé un avantage
personnel et il ne compte pas davantage
que la collectivité ou non étaient
effectivement les et cette
interprétation est sans doute conformes
à la finalité du texte l'incrimination
qui vise à éviter qu'une personne
chargée d'une fonction publique ne s'en
sert dans un intérêt personnel ou puisse
seulement être soupçonné de ne pas
ennuyer conformément à l'intérêt général
comme l'indiquait le conseiller d'état
rapportant devant le corps législatif la
cie février 1810 d'importants donc les
dispositions relatives au délit
d'ingérence dans le site
la considération qui environnent les
fonctionnaires les principalement de la
confiance qu'ils inspirent et tout ce
qui peut altérer cette confiance ou
dégrader leur caractère doit leur est
interdit mais entre un donneur des élus
pourront participer au vote de
subventions destinées à des associations
dont il assurait la présidence
la présidence la juste 20 ans récente a
fait peser une épée de damoclès
au-dessus de la tête de tout élu
fonctionnaires nul si on est 6 intègre
soit il ne peut prétendre être à l'abri
des poursuites sauf à vivre en ermite
dans sa ville il résulte de cette
pesante incertitude juridique un risque
de paralysie de l'action publique locale
a souligné
et surtout un profond sentiment de
malaise dont témoignent les exemples
concrets qui ont été présentés par nos
collègues de la commission des lois
en réalité cette situation délictuelle
s'arrête là où le soupçon n'a plus cours
et il appartient au juge du conte de
fées
le partage entre les cas où la décision
publique ne peut être soupçonné de
partialité et ceux où elle peut l'être
pertes
fort heureusement les magistrats savent
faire la part des choses et prononce des
peines symboliques
lorsque la probité de l'élu au du
fonctionnaire n'est pas en cause il n'en
reste pas moins qu'une condamnation
fut-elle de principe n'est jamais neutre
donc face à de telles approximations et
écosse
que faire la marge de manoeuvre est
étroite tant il est vrai que dans une
matière aussi sensible
une réforme peut alimenter le soupçon de
thau amnistie et est que mal accueillie
par l'opinion publique
il nous appartient donc de réagir sans
la moindre ambiguïté et avec la plus
grande fermeté
oui la lutte contre toutes les formes de
corruption et au préalable indispensable
à l'autorité de l'état
raison de plus pour refuser les
amalgames les plus doux tu ne rien faire
c'est accepter des élus ou des
fonctionnaires soient injustement livré
à la vindicte publique et contribué à
alimenter le sentiment du tous fruits
sans doute faut-il d'abord et avant tout
renforcer la prévention c'est à dire
l'information
la bonne connaissance du risque par les
élus quelle qu'en soit la nature dans
les faits une condition sinequanone à sa
mesure à sa maîtrise mais convenez
monsieur vie lisse que les arguments
juridiques ne monte pas en faveur d'une
révision de l'article 432-12 du code
pénal ont là je crois suffisamment
démontré sa rédaction n'est pas
satisfaisante et apprennent les
situations kafkaïennes vous l'avez dit
vous-même la proposition de loi qui nous
est présenté aujourd'hui vise à
remplacer le terme les termes intérêt
quel compte nous sommes très aléatoire
par les termes intérêt personnel
distinct de l'intérêt général qui vise
l'intérêt particulier
je le vois donc pas quel mauvais signal
vous avez eu à l'opinion publique et
même aux instances internationales
loin de diminuer la responsabilité des
élus le texte apporte plus de sérénité
dans la gestion publique locale
on ne peut accepter que les élus
désertent les associations le voici gfk
lité comme haut représentant de l'ue aux
collectivités par peur d'être poursuivis
cela pose un vrai problème en termes de
contrôle pas la collectivité du bon
usage des fonds par les associations
qu'elle sut faut qu'elles subventionnent
on l'a dit avant moi c'est pourquoi
le groupe rdse à son entier et ce n'est
pas souvent le cas votre à ce texte
peut-être même qu'il souhaitait une
réflexion plus large sur les zones de
fragilité des élus locaux gestion de
fait favoritisme accident au cours d'une
manifestation marchés publics
délégations de service public
liquidation aux prises d'un passif d'une
association subventionnée au prix d'une
activité en régie la jurisprudence sur
tous ces sujets témoignent de leur
complexité
en tout cas pour le moment c'est sans
hésiter que nous voterons ce texte
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci enchères collègues la discussion
générale close
nous passons à la discussion du texte
élaboré par la commission sur l'article
unique je ne suis saisi d'aucun
amendements je vais donc mettre aux voix
l'article unique constitue un ensemble
monsieur le ministre prie de m'excuser
je j'allais vous vous demandez la parole
et j'étais distrait par les
félicitations que j'adressais aux
derniers intervenants
je voulais mais je serais extrêmement
bref mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
après avoir écouté non seulement le
l'auteur le rapporteur mais également
monsieur yves detraigne monsieur pierre
yves collombat monsieur jean pierre vial
madame eliane assassi le sundance à part
dont ça n'était pas terminée si si à oui
pardon et monsieur données de mars at je
voulais simplement mais d'une phrase
dire que j'ai bien entendu vos remarques
est également le fruit de votre
expérience de terrain sur ce sujet vous
avez encore aujourd'hui enrichi le débat
en commission
je voulais simplement ajouté que le
gouvernement a compris la démarche de
votre commission des lois celle de
concilier deux impératifs qui
garantissent notre vie démocratique
enfin la neutralité à laquelle doit se
soumettre strictement tout agent public
élus ou fonctionnaires et la nécessité
juridique qui fait du en contrepartie
nous avons bien conscience que notre que
votre proposition ne vise pas à réduire
le champ d'application du délit de prise
illégale d'intérêt des élus locaux mais
simplement de le préciser
vu des arguments que vous avez développé
que j'ai entendu les observations que je
vous ai adressé au nom du gouvernement
ne sont en effet pas incompatible avec
la nécessaire réflexion que le sénat a
engagé également la clarification
recherché je partage bien sûr vos
préoccupations des élus locaux
confrontés comme vous l'avez fort bien
dit parfois la difficulté de
l'application de la loi pénale et c'est
donc avec les réserves et et remarque
que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure et à
l'instant que je vous confirme que le
gouvernement s'en remet donc à la
sagesse du sénat
merci monsieur le ministre j'ai une
demande d'explications de vote
monsieur faucher très brièvement madame
la présidente monsieur le ministre
d'abord c'est un très bon texte et je
félicite le bernard saugey ensuite
madame escoffier qui a travaillé sur ce
texte qui s'est fait d'une manière très
plurielle avec d'autres parlementaires
bon se croient que c'est un test et
essentiel je suis un élu de terrain les
avocats aussi comme un certain nombre
d'entre nous et je me souviens et
quelques années les gens étaient
complètement traumatisée et la loi
fauchon est arrivée et elle a permis
d'enlever tous ces traumatismes je me
souviens notamment cette fameuse
histoire de deux bus qui avait été qui
avait tué un enfant dans un stade sur un
stade à la rochelle et la loi fo sont là
dedans à en arrivant a quand même bien
géré les choses
alors c'est vrai que l'intérêt
quelconque est quelque chose de très
risqué il ya très risqué et un risque
permanent et les uns les autres vous
avez pris des exemples mer dont le
petit-fils ou dans un club au
département c'est vrai qu'on entend très
souvent je siège au département de la
vienne on entend très souvent les élus
tous aurions qu'ils disent
qu'ils disent au directeur ne mettait
pas dit que je ne participe pas au vote
mais effectivement il ya ce risque là
aussi il peut y avoir des dérives
jurisprudentielle même si on n'a pas
beaucoup aujourd'hui donc avec tous les
risques que ça présente une fois que la
condamnation est prononcée incapacité
ecti va perdre des droits de physique
civique
donc tout ça peut être très grave donc
je crois qu'il s'agit comme d'un assaut
je le disais de protéger les élus
honnêtes je pas que parler d'intérêt
personnel mais pareil beaucoup mieux et
beaucoup peut correspondre aux souhaits
que qui est le nôtre pour un bon
fonctionnement des choses donc par
conséquent je voterai merci chers
collègues
y at il d'autres demandes d'explications
de vote il n'y en a pas je mets donc aux
voiles article unique constitue un
ensemble de la proposition de loi
ceux qui sont favorables à son adoption
voudront bien l'exprimer en levant la
main
unanimité je vous en remercie monsieur
sauget en quelques instants main dans la
présidente remercier toutes les
personnes qui ont participé à ce débat
aussi bien en commission conscience
publique jouets remercie en particulier
notre président de la commission des
lois jean jacques hyest est notre
rapporteur anne marie escoffier qui a
fait un très très gros travail je le
remercie allah était tout à fait dans le
dans l'esprit du texte je voudrais aussi
associer une fois de plus mon collègue
et ami père yves collombat parce que
nous sommes les deux pères spirituels en
fait y en a pas qu'un nous sommes deux
sur le faire et je voudrais que ce soit
bien compris car lui en tant que vice
président national des maires ruraux en
particulier il a fait un gros travail là
dessus aussi remercié également
tous nos amis qui sont intervenus au
titre de leur groupe politique
bien sûr il détraigne lui il a été
magistral époque à la chambre régionale
des comptes donc il connaît les choses
pierre yves collombat je viens d'en
parler jean pierre vial lui aussi a été
président de conseil général et brillant
avocat également alain fouché il vient
de le dire qu'il était avocat bien
entendu il y associe aussi bien entendu
et je suis content que le groupe crc s'y
associent daniel marsin pour le rds
parce que effectivement on se rend
compte que sur tous les bancs de cette
assemblée
tout le monde a été unanime pour voter
cette proposition de loi qui à mon avis
tombe sous le sens monsieur le ministre
je tiens vous remercie également parce
que dans l'évolution de votre estimation
des choses lorsque vous êtes arrivé il y
a trois semaines effectivement en
commission des lois
vous vous étiez j'allais dire des
offices en la matière et on vous avait
donné un texte que vous aviez lu et ma
foi
effectivement vous n'étiez pas au
courant du contexte général j'allais
dire et je vous remercie d'avoir pris de
votre temps pour l'évolution de la
position du gouvernement sur cette
affaire
le fait d'arriver à la sagesse nous
convient tout à fait parfaitement
et vous le voyez d'ailleurs c'est à
l'unanimité je suis assez fier de la
haute assemblée pour ce genre de choses
parce que nous savons avoir les pieds
sur terre et tenir compte de l'intérêt
général
j'espère simplement et j'ai déjà pris
quelques contacts que nos amis
parlementaires députés auront à coeur de
faire inscrire cette proposition de loi
rapidement car eux aussi ils sont élus
comme nous ils sont élus ils sont
présidentes conseillers généraux ils
sont verts ils sont présents conseillers
régionaux
donc je pense que pourrait aussi ça les
concerne directement
je pense qu'ils ont un coeur
effectivement d'avoir cette inscription
rapide
je vous remercie tous merci et chaque
collègue merci monsieur ministre bernard
saugey a donc souhaité clarifier la
notion de prise illégale d'intérêt afin
dit-il
d'enlever l épée de damoclès au-dessus
de la tête des élus ch est la prise
illégale d'intérêt est passible de cinq
ans de prison
il a donc souhaité elle limitait les
poursuites pénales aux seuls élus qui en
retire un bénéfice personnel
cet après midi et les sénateurs
examinent une proposition de loi
communiste sur le recours collectif ce
recours permet à plusieurs consommateurs
victimes d'un même préjudice d'engager
des poursuites commune vous pourrez
suivre en direct sur public sénat à
partir de 15h ce débat dans l'hémicycle
est très bonne journée